arizona and montana are suing to block
president biden's rules which would
dramatically
narrow the number of illegal immigrants
ice agents
arrest or deport
the states argue the policies would have
devastating consequences
and it's likely already happening the
washington post is reporting that ice
data show
the number of arrests under biden
already fell
by more than 60 percent last month
compared with the last three months of
the trump administration
and the deportations fell by nearly that
same amount
joining me now from one of the states
the two that are suing the biden
administration
montana attorney general austin knudsen
good to see you today
first of all tell me exactly what is
happening potentially already and why
well we filed lawsuit in in the federal
court
harris asking the court to stop
this this order from president biden
look this is devastating for states like
arizona
and you might be thinking well why is
montana join this lawsuit
this is devastating for states like
montana too and frankly it's put the
whole country in danger
violent crime in montana has risen by 48
percent
just since 2013 harris and we know this
is from the
mexican drug cartels smuggling drugs up
through the unsecured southern border
this is just going gonna keep getting
worse under this moratorium order from
president biden and that's why we've
sued
all right well let me ask you this
attorney general uh
you know where do they go if ice agents
are not arresting them and and i asked
that because i know from looking at
montana's records that
meth is such a huge problem and you're
talking about the drug cartels bringing
it into your state
so you're aware that these people are
there what impact does it have if biden
doesn't have ice agents rounding them up
where are they
it has a huge impact harris they're
they're coming in the country they're
spreading out to the interior
you know people i think people
mistakenly think this is just a southern
state problem a california problem an
arizona problem and it certainly is but
it's also a northern state problem
like i said i mean our largest city here
in montana billings montana
88 increase in meth related crime just
in the last couple years i mean violent
crime has spiked
dramatically in montana and i can tell
you this is 100
tied to the drug cartels in mexico and
from the illegal immigrants that are
smuggling
these poisons into our state this is a
huge crisis for a state like montana and
that's why we've jumped in the city
so how is your law enforcement able to
handle that because that that sounds
like a big job 88
in any crime category would be big but
in this one in particular
yeah well frankly they're not i mean our
our law enforcement is stretched thin as
it is we're a very
large state geographically but we're a
very small state population wise you
know we're just over a million people
we don't have a lot of law enforcement
and they're covering a huge geographic
territory
uh the montana highway patrol they
patrol thousands and thousands of miles
of highway
but there's only 200 of them so this is
a huge issue our law enforcement is
stretched
absolutely thin there's no way we can
keep up with it
tell me just real quickly what some of
the citizens are telling you i mean
you're at the attorney general's office
so people will call and they'll say this
is what i'm experiencing with a spike
like that of 88
in crime that that you say it's tied to
what's coming across the border
and it makes sense methamphetamine
coming from the cartels
yeah look i'm i'm from a very rural part
of the state i'm a former a former
prosecutor i've dealt with this in the
last few years
we see it all over the state it's it's a
problem in our cities
it's a problem in our counties it's a
problem in our rural areas people i
think don't realize that
you see it all over the state of montana
it's by far the number one thing i hear
about
it's the biggest reason why i ran for
attorney general and frankly that's why
i take this this move from president
biden so seriously
and why we jumped in this lawsuit this
this is a huge deal for states like
montana
quick yes or no do you anticipate more
states will join you in arizona montana
and arizona in this
i do yes okay got it
attorney general knudsen from the great
state of montana we will bring you back
to get the latest on this thank you
very much for your time appreciate it